el gobierno ruso es el gran ausente de
la conferencia de seguridad de múnich
este año y es una ausencia
particularmente significativa en el
contexto actual en el que precisamente
se está discutiendo sobre la posibilidad
de un ataque ruso a ucrania rusia es el
tema de la conferencia de seguridad de
este año con la ministra de relaciones
exteriores de alemania anna-lena ve a
boca explicando en su intervención que
no se trata actualmente de una crisis de
ucrania como ha sido descrita
ampliamente sino de una crisis de rusia
el análisis del gobierno alemán que
asegura que el peligro de un ataque ruso
a ucrania es muy real así como la
intervención en washington de joe biden
el presidente de eeuu asegurando que
eeuu considera que tropas rusas
pretenden atacar ucrania en cuestión de
días marcan el tono marcan la agenda de
la conferencia de seguridad este sábado
en la que los participantes están
discutiendo precisamente nuevas maneras
de escalar está muy delicada situación